concerns and conversations about how  dark his skin might be when he's born  what what was that conversation  that conversation I'm never going to  share all right then keep your secret  guys  he's so ethical this Harry I'm stronger  I'm smarter  I'm better  I am better he's never gonna share the  conversation that they had about the  baby being too dark but he'll tell it to  Megan and then Megan can tell Oprah and  then Oprah can ask him about it but he's  not going to share any information about  that conversation look I don't know if  it's true or not true but the broader  point is they are using the power that I  mean just imagine to be given all the  privilege that they have been given and  use it to destroy the thing that gave  you the privilege